do you know that there's a trial right
now going on
of guillain maxwell gelain maxwell the
partner in crime to jeffrey epstein who
totally killed himself
of his own volition
acts it was accidentally permitted to
happen in that manhattan correctional
facility totally totally killed himself
and if you say otherwise you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist you know jeffrey
epstein the guy who had creepy pedo
island where he invited all the world
leaders and
largely democrat some republicans do but
largely democrats and libs
you know so elaine maxwell now is still
alive which is impressive and she's
she's on trial
we have not discussed the trial very
much on the show it's been going on for
about a week now
the reason i haven't discussed the trial
is one i'm still holding out hope that
the deep state will give me a big
payment not to talk about i ass
everyone's on the take from the deep
state except me how come no one's
offering me any money come on i'll i'll
play ball guys come on no they won't
call me no the reason i haven't talked
about it
is not because the story isn't
interesting and
titillating and terrifying and creepy
it's because there's there's no new
information
this is the scariest part of all
this we're not learning anything
what are we learning in in the trial
they're naming all the names of the
people who were on epstein's
airplanes we already knew that we knew
all those people were on the airplanes
we're finding out that jeffrey epstein
gillane maxwell visited the clinton
white house a lot
yeah we already knew that guillain was
at chelsea clinton's wedding
which we've known for years which the
media knew for years and years before
they would even touch the story it was
only a handful of conservatives who
would say hey what about this creepy guy
jeffrey epstein then finally
we we know
all of this
that's what's so depressing about
the whole affair
know
that the ruling class is deeply
implicated in the affairs of jeffrey
epstein this bizarre international man
of mystery who has apparently strange
ties to international intelligence who
we don't really know where he got his
money from we know he was surveilling
and blackmailing people it was
everything about it is just so we know
he got a sweetheart deal when he was
first brought up on the weird sex
charges we know that the united states
attorney at the time
under bush said uh jeffrey epstein
belongs to intelligence
so don't don't touch him and he gets
this sweetheart deal and then finally
they get him again some years later
after that we know all of that
so we know
the ruling class knows that we know
and we know that the ruling class knows
that we know
and it just doesn't matter this is why
that the meme jeffrey epstein didn't
kill himself this is why it became a
meme
right because no one thinks that this
guy was just sort of accidentally
allowed to kill himself and whoops the
camera that was on his cell just
accidentally went out and whoops the
guards that were checking on him just
accidentally
fell asleep
right at the perfect time so that no one
believes that
and the ruling class doesn't care
because what are you going to do about
it
what are you going to do
you know when you look at the
intelligence community
component of all of this
i'm reminded of that phrase from chuck
schumer
right when the deep state you know it's
not the deep state it's not a conspiracy
theory it's just the administrative
agencies with a particular focus on the
intelligence community we know that that
exists and that they have priorities
that they can pursue regardless of who
is in the white house and we know that
they can undermine duly elected
presidents they did it to trump they
cooked up a totally fake steel dossier
this and they used that as an excuse to
spy on him and to undermine his
administration and to plant lots of
bogus theories that got the guy
impeached twice
but
regardless
what are you going to do about it
what are you
going to do about it nothing
chuck schumer the line from chuck
schumer was don't go up against the
intelligence community they can get you
nine ways from sunday
and he was being honest they can it's a
very powerful force
in not just american politics but in
global
politics so that's why we what is there
to talk about
there's nothing to talk the real story
is not
whatever creepy massage jeffrey epstein
got on pedo island
the real story is
how did epstein become so powerful where
did he get his money
how did he so successfully blackmail
these people
what
what privileges did he get because he
had all this dirt on everybody who was
backing him did you like that clip i'm
glad i'm glad you like that thank you
very much it makes me feel good
please subscribe
ring the bell
make sure you get notifications not just
for the show here on youtube but if you
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast you type in th e
space
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-space canada w-l-e-s space
s-h-o-w subscribe
leave a five-star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you